- [Sal] In a previous video,
we talk about the notion of
equivalence with equations.
And equivalence is just this notion
that there's different ways of writing
what our equivalent statements in algebra.
And I can give some simple examples.
I could say two x equals 10,
or I could say x equals five.
These are equivalent equations.
Why are they?
Because an x satisfies one of them
if and only if it satisfies the other.
And you can verify that in both cases,
x equals five is the only
x that satisfies both.
Another set of equivalent
equations, you could have two x
is equal to eight and x equals four.
These two are equivalent equations.
An x satisfies one if and only
if it satisfies the other.
In this video, we're going
to extend our knowledge
of equivalence to thinking
about equivalent systems.
And really, in your past
when you were solving
systems of equations,
you were doing operations
assuming equivalence, but you might not
have just been thinking about it that way.
So let's give ourselves a system.
So let's say this system tells us
that there's some x y pair
where two times that x
plus that y is equal to eight,
and that x plus that y is equal to five.
Now we can have an equivalent system
if we replace either of these equations
with an equivalent version.
So for example, many of you when you look
to try to solve this, you might say well,
if this was a negative two x here,
maybe I could eventually
add the left side.
And we'll talk about why that is
an equivalence preserving operation.
But in order to get a
negative two out here,
you'd have to multiply
this entire equation
times negative two.
And so if you did that, if you
multiplied both sides of this
times negative two, times negative two,
what you're going to get is negative two x
minus two y is equal to negative 10.
This equation and this
equation are equivalent.
Why?
Because any x y pair that
satisfies one of them
will satisfy the other, or
an x y pair satisfies one
if and only if it satisfies the other.
And so if I now think about the system,
the system where I've
rewritten this second equation
and my first equation is the same,
this is an equivalent
system to our first system.
So these, any x y pair, if an x y pair
satisfies one of these systems,
it's going to satisfy
the other and vice versa.
Now the next interesting
thing that you might realize,
and if you were just trying to solve this,
and this isn't an introductory
video in solving systems,
so I'm assuming some familiarity with it,
you've probably seen
solving by elimination
where you say okay, look,
if I can somehow add these,
the left side to the left
side and the right side
to the right side, these
x's will quote cancel out
and then I'll just be left with y's.
And we've done this before.
You can kind of think you're
trying to solve for y.
But in this video, I
want to think about why
you end up with an equivalent system
if you were to do that.
And one way to think about it is
what I'm going to do to create
an equivalent system here
is I am going to keep my first equation,
two x plus y is equal to eight.
But then I'm gonna take my second equation
and add the same thing to both sides.
We know if you add or
subtract the same thing
to both sides of an equation,
you get an equivalent equation.
So I'm gonna do that over here.
But it's gonna be a
little bit interesting.
So if you had negative two x minus two y
is equal to negative 10,
and what I want to do
is I want to add eight to both sides.
So I could do it like this.
I could add eight to both sides.
But remember, our system
is saying that both
of these statements are true,
that two x plus y is equal to eight
and negative two x minus two
y is equal to negative 10.
So instead of adding
explicitly eight to both sides,
I could add something that's equivalent
to eight to both sides.
And I know something that
is equivalent to eight
based on this first equation.
I could add eight, and I could do eight
on the left hand side, or I
could just add two x plus y.
So two x plus y.
Now I really want you, you
might want to pause your video
and say okay, how can I do this?
Why is Sal saying that I'm adding
the same thing to both sides?
Because remember, when
we're taking a system,
we're assuming that both
of these need to be true.
An x y pair satisfies one
equation if and only if,
only if, if and only if
it satisfies the other.
So here, we know that x, two x plus y
needs to be equal to eight.
So if I'm adding two x plus y to the left
and I'm adding eight to the right,
I'm really just adding
eight to both sides,
which is equivalence preserving.
And when you do that, you
get, these negative two x
and two x cancels out, you get negative y
is equal to negative two.
And so I can rewrite that second equation
as negative y is equal to negative two.
And I know what you're thinking.
You're like wait, but I'm used
to solving systems of equations.
I'm used to just adding these two together
and then I just have this one equation.
And really, that's not super
mathematically rigorous
because the other equation is still there.
It's still a constraint.
Oftentimes, you solve for one
and then you quote substitute back in.
But really, the both equations
are there the whole time.
You're just rewriting
them in equivalent ways.
So once again, this system, this system,
and this system are all equivalent.
Any x y pair that
satisfies one will satisfy
all of them, and vice versa.
And once again, we can continue
to rewrite this in equivalent ways.
That second equation, I can multiply
both sides by negative one.
That's equivalence preserving.
And if I did that, then
I get, I haven't changed
my top equation, two x
plus y is equal to eight.
And on the second one,
if I multiply both sides
by negative one, I get y is equal to two.
Once again, these are
all equivalent systems.
I know I'm, I sound
very repetitive in this.
But now, I can do another
thing to make this,
to keep the equivalence
but get a clearer idea
of what that x y pair is.
If we know that y is equal to two
and we know that that's
true in both equations,
remember, it is an and here.
We're assuming there's x y, some x y pair
that satisfies both.
Two x plus y needs to be equal to eight
and y is equal to two.
Well that means up here where we see a y,
we can write an equivalent system
where instead of writing a y there,
we could write a two because
we know that y is equal to two.
And so we can rewrite that top equation
by substituting a two for y.
So we could rewrite that as two
x plus two is equal to eight
and y is equal to two.
So this is an and right over there.
It's implicitly there.
And of course, we can
keep going from there.
I'll scroll down a little bit.
I could write another
equivalent system to this
by doing equivalence preserving operations
on that top equation.
What if I subtracted two from both sides
of that top equation?
It's still going to be
an equivalent equation.
And so I could rewrite
it as, if I subtract two
from both sides, I'm gonna
get two x is equal to six.
And then that second
equation hasn't changed.
Y is equal to two.
So there's some x y pair
that if it satisfies one,
it satisfies the other, and vice versa.
This system is equivalent to every system
that I've written so far in
this chain of operations,
so to speak, and then of
course, this top equation,
an equivalence preserving operation
is to divide both sides by a non,
the same nonzero value.
And in this case, I could
divide both sides by two.
And then I would get, if
I divide the top by two,
I would get x equals three,
and y is equal to two.
And once again, this is a different way
of thinking about it.
All I'm doing is rewriting the same system
in an equivalent way that just
gets us a little bit clearer
as to what that x y pair actually is.
In the past, you might've just, you know,
just assumed that you can
add both sides of an equation
or do this type of elimination
or do some type of substitution
to just quote figure out the x and y.
But really, you're rewriting the system.
You're rewriting the
constraints of the system
in equivalent ways to
make it more explicit
what that x y pair is that satisfies
both equations in the system.